dozens of has he gone there to show his
support for the Israeli government after
what they've been
doing brothers and sisters just imagine
for a second that you give 1010 in
donation and that1 is used to buy food
or bricks or whatever to help the people
in Gaza but then just imagine this
amazing D that you want to do but we
turn it into a money-making machine how
the W is exactly that they take your
money and the money that we are going to
put in in this W this building and every
single time the money generated from
that W that building is going to go to
our Palestinian brothers and sisters for
the next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years
and this will be a form of
true I myself will be donating for that
inshah click the link below and donate
may Allah subhana bless and preserve you
guys brothers and sisters and dear
friends Elon Musk has gone to Israel and
his has met the main Satan himself which
is Benjamin Netanyahu he's gone there
for I don't know what reason but they
taking him through what apparently Hamas
did on 7th of October before that
brother sisters my video is being
shadowbanned there's a very bizarre
thing happening I've been doing this for
10 years the video I released about the
hostages being released and being
threatened by Israel has had all of a
sudden a h please go to that video and
share it as much as possible because I
think they're trying to stop it Elon
Musk came and spoke out against the
oppression Israel was doing if if you're
not going to just outright commit
genocide like it against an entire
people which obviously would not be
acceptable to to to really shouldn't be
acceptable to anyone then you you're
going to leave basically a lot of people
alive who subsequently you know hate
Israel so really the question is like
for for every Hamas member that you kill
how many did you create and so much so
that he was accused of anti-Semitism as
usual it's the card that they use sadly
not that we saying it's not real but
they use it anywhere and everywhere just
to shut people up and it doesn't work so
some of the companies even started to
boycott ex or Twitter for that matter
and I think this pressure maybe got to
Elon Musk maybe we don't know here is
the footage where he is being shown the
attack that happened in uh October 7th
but they forgot about October 5th
October 6th 5th 4th 3rd 2nd 1st and all
those other hundreds or thousands of
days uh since the occupation has started
here is a footage of Elon Musk and that
evil Satan Benjamin
netan dozens
of
when the terrorists infiltrated into the
Kut
itself most
of the
hous so guys as you saw for yourself if
I'm not mistaken Elon Musk said that
he's going to provide internet for the
guarden people for the Palestinians with
the stalling but there was an official
statement made by one of Benjamin
Netanyahu satans the little satans yeah
there's a big Satan the little satans
that this is only going to happen with
the permission of Israel for that matter
so now we do not know what's exactly
happening because has he gone there to
you know show you know his support for
the Israeli government after what
they've been doing and they're showing
all this stuff that happened on October
7th and if you even look at it their own
officials have their commanders IDF
soldiers and not only that haret their
newspaper has even been on the fire for
claiming and showing outright evidence
that they have this a a a protocol
called hanbal that it allows them to hit
and shoot their own
civilians
that was Israeli Colonel nois claimed
the Israeli Army had implemented a
notorious military Doctrine known as the
Hannibal protocol standard Israeli Army
procedure forbids soldiers from firing
and the direction of their colleagues
but the Hannibal directive allows for
this order to be suspended the aim is to
prevent Israeli troops from falling into
enemy hands in order to leave no scope
for negotiation or Ru for Israeli
soldiers to be used as bargaining ships
y Kat who surviv the kibot bar attacks
has also accused the Israeli Army of
invoking the directive
and reports emerged of Israeli military
helicopters using artillery against
civilians at the Nova Music Festival
these Revelations counter the Army's
claims that Hamas was responsible for
the deaths of approximately 12200
Israelis and in October the 7 if you saw
the shelling and saw what happened to
those cars that are on fire blown up the
houses these are not things that can be
done by the the by equipment that Hamas
has for that matter it is evident that
they are the ones who killed their own
civilians we're not saying all or
majority of them where they were told to
indiscriminately fire which is a policy
that they have in Warfare in their own
protocols that they use so they are
going there and showing these things I
want to ask el musk have you gone to
Gaza have you gone to Palestine and
seeing what these criminals have done
these real terrorists these criminals
who have killed even over 15,000 people
9,000 innocent babies children and kids
he's gone there and they're saying that
he would only be able to provide
Starling internet access under the
permission of Israel which is
understandable because if it's not in
control whatever is for that matter I
don't know if you can do something about
it or not but I want to go to this ay in
the Quran Allah subhana wa T says when
the Angels asked him because Allah subh
knew what was going to happen Allah says
in the
Quan because the Angels asked very
profound subh
Allah
Allah subhana T said remember when your
lord said to the angels I am going to
place a successive human authority on
Earth they asked Allah will you place in
it someone who was spread corruption
there and still and shed blood while we
glorify and praise your Proclaim and
your Holiness Allah responded I know
what you do not know and the matter here
is this brother and sisters we do not
need Elon Musk or anyone for that matter
we always try to rely on people we do
not need it we need to stop taking our
logic over the Allah has promised us we
do not need starlink to have a
connection to Allah subhana wa tala we
don't need any internet connection no
satellites needed for us to have a
connection with Allah subhana wa tala
especially the oppressed there is no
barrier between the oppressed and the
ones who are asking Allah for guidance
we don't need Starling we don't need
ilas we don't need nobody if the entire
Globe came to stop the communication
they could never bear that in mind
everything is in the control of Allah
subhana and it's a test for me and you
brother and sisters do not ever lose
hope don't rely on Elon Musk do not rely
on anybody we do not trust any of them
for that matter we have Allah subhana
tala and Allah will give Victory they
have caused 15,000 martys and Jenna is
what is Promised for them inshallah you
should be sorry for yourself and myself
we need to do more we need to boycott
product have you gone to your local
supermarket and seen your local off
licenses or whatever for that matter and
seen that if they are selling these
dates or these products that belong to
Israel tell them to boycott we need to
start this movement and boycott and very
strangely enough subh brother sisters
like I said you before in the beginning
of the video they have all of a sudden
I've been doing YouTube for 10 years I
had a sudden Hal in My Views when it
came to the hostages that have been
threatened by Israel so you can clearly
see brother and sisters they are they
are trying to Shadow B my Channel or
some the videos for that matter it had
the automatic St di which is very
bizarre so brother and sisters go and
share that video because it's showing
you that it is hurting them and they're
going to do everything to stop us and we
will not stop inshallah so all I'm going
to say brothers and sisters Allah
subhana Tal's promise is true and W it
is true stick to that do not r on elas
we have Allah subhana wa tala and that's
the only thing that we need and we don't
need any Starling to connect to him
alhamdulillah pray to him pray for the
people in Gaza boycot this product share
these videos inshallah and go and watch
that video that I'm going to link
because they are trying to Shadow ban it
inallah as the hostages have you can see
the relation between the Israeli
hostages and the Hamas leaders compared
to the hostages that were kept the
Palestinian hostages with Israeli forces
there is day and night of difference
Subhan Allah that's all I want to say
may allow the Jewish Christians and
Muslims come and live together in peace
and Harmony till next
time brothers and sisters just imagine
for a second that you give1 in donation
and that £10 is used to buy food or
bricks or whatever to help the people in
Gaza but then just imagine this amazing
D that you want to do but we turn it
into a moneymaking machine how the W is
exactly that they take your money and
the money that we are going to put in in
this W this building and every single
time the money generated from that W
that building is going to go to our
Palestinian brothers and sisters for the
next 20 30 40 50 60 100 150 years and
this will be a form of
true I myself will be donating for that
inshah click the link below and donate
may Allah subhana bless and preserve you
guys we will together inshallah see the
day when Palestine will be
free